ich habe mir das ist
sie ist schon bewusst dass das nur eine
puppe ist es komplett draußen heute seid
ihr auch könnten daneben wo ihr probleme
habt im alltag aber ihr einfach nicht
wisst wir sie bewältigen sollten
probleme werden immer größer die lasten
auf euch und er hat das gefühl er ist
kein ausweg mehr immer wenn man im leben
an diesem punkt angekommen es gibt es
dafür einen sehr einfachen grund man hat
einfach nicht genug ratgeber serien
geschaut aber keine sorge leute ich bin
natürlich feuchter und habt ihr euch
eine folge die euch persönlich im alltag
weiter bringen wird und zwar geht es um
den ganz klassischen fall dass eine
person denkt ihre puppe sei ein echtes
baby
ja macht sinn denn das video ist schon
heißt wenn das baby ist nur eine
plastikpuppe fangen wir an
[Musik]
ja das ist der punkt an dem ihr
mittlerweile in deutschland angekommen
sind leute menschen kommen einfach so
krass nicht mehr in ihrem leben klar
dass sie denken plastikpuppen werden
echte kinder und die ziehen das wollte
ich nie hat ein kinderwagen für das ding
der opfer da hat gerade einfach den
kinderwagen um gefahren die rost voll
aus
das ding ist aus plastik
keine sorge das nur aus plastik
so wie ich bin ich bin ein bisschen
durchgeknallt ja ich denke dass ich mein
echtes baby ist ja klingt verrückt
ja ich habe dachschaden ist das alles
nicht aber jetzt kommt jetzt kommt die
leute jetzt kommt der moment wo sie
realisieren dass die tante einfach denn
absolut geisteskrank ist ein dachschaden
aller zeiten hat sie drückt seinem kopf
rumpf der vorsaison ein echtes baby und
sie hat einfach nur keine ahnung den
fingernagel der frau angefasst denkt
deswegen das kind der plastik drückt man
so im kopf rum
das war doch recht
jetzt habe ich kaputt gemacht fakt ist
ja angefahren habe general
sie brauchen unbedingt hilfe
die braucht tatsächlich hilfe
tatsächlich gut worauf wird die frau
braucht tatsächlich hilft man könnte
möglicherweise denken sie sei an der
richtigen stelle wenn sie in einer
sendung auftaucht die hilft mir heißt
könnte man denken praktisch gesehen das
hatte ich totaler bullshit beihilfen mir
niemals einen menschen wirklich geholfen
wird alles was passiert ist was wir
heute gezeigt dass leute im dachschaden
linda ist verzweifelt doch auch vor dem
kasten hat kein verständnis für die 32
jährige ja besser so besser so alt da
muss man auch kein verständnis für haben
also generell wir leben in einer zeit wo
man irgendwie verständnis für alles
möglich haben soll aber irgendwo ist
auch schluss anbieter wenn er erwachsene
frau zu mir kommt und mir erzählen will
dass ihre baby born puppe ein echtes
baby ist die nada ist einfach kopfschuss
zeit das sei dann reicht's einfach
[Musik]
das finden mein sohn befinden wurde
gerade angefahren
ja okay du hast recht ich gehe einfach
selbst in die geschlossene anstalt super
wie kommt man auch so was ganz ehrlich
also respekt vor den leuten die diese
stories schreiben weil ich werde im
leben nicht aufgekommen
wer sitzt im büro und denkt sich eines
tages aus wir bringen wir eine frau die
denkt ihr kind einfach ja so fühle ich
mich in der regel auch wenn ich diese
videos sehen wollt ihr mich verarschen
es ist euer ernst aus dieser titel leute
in das baby ist nur eine plastikpuppe
ist kann es eigentlich nicht sein
becker sogar noch einen ganz anderen
level leiter können wir so nicht so
persönliche die pistor ist einfach
rauslassen und einfach scheiße labern
die klammern wir jetzt mal den ganzen
hintergrund aus wissen was meine erste
reaktion wäre wenn irgendwas mit kommen
wir dann sagen würde das ist eine
plastikpuppe das ist mein sohn finn
vielleicht ein bisschen extremer ich
glaub ich mir das ding einfach nehmen
und gegen die wand werfen einfach so um
zu zeigen wie soll eine plastikpuppe die
ein drei monate altes kind darstellt
verstehen wenn zwei menschen über
figuren
ich kann da kommen nicht so ganz
dahinter leute gebt mir nicht im kopf
dass auch ihre standards mir egal was
irgendwann zu ihr sagt sie will nicht
drüber reden bist du am sonntagmorgen
beim bäcker will sich endlich
brötchenholen die bäckerei fachen so
guten morgen was das für sie sein
ich will gar nicht drüber reden nach dem
autounfall braucht länder unbedingt
einen neuen kinderwagen für ihr baby
denn für film ist der 32 jährigen das
beste gerade gut genug
ach du scheiße das 32 das ist wirklich
schockierend
ach nein sich vorzustellen dass das
wirklich passieren könnte das hemmt so
die lust aufs eigene leben ziemlich
stark meine tochter hat auch gerade
einen sohn bekommen
jetzt suche ich auch ein geschenk für
sie ganz ehrlich das auch so kripo oder
schlecht man vorher eine frau im alltag
und sie ist so mit ihrem kind zu haben
nun wittert das und dann seht ihr aber
das aus plastik ist das richtig creepy
oder glaube da würde ich gänsehaut
bekommen in dem moment ist doch ganz
normal ist doch 2009/10 jeder kann
selbst entscheiden ob ein gegenstand
lebt oder nicht
so was habe ich erlebt
[Musik]
ich bin entsetzt wie können sie eine
puppe in diesen laden mitnehmen es ist
kein spaß hier sie übertreibt einfach
komplett ihre rolle so zimmer das ist
nicht so als würdest du panzer verkaufen
okay du verkaufst kinderwagen angeht
also ich muss sagen ganz ehrlich also
solange sie bei uns einkaufen und
komplett egal und gibt natürlich auch
komplett egal ob sie geistig behindert
sind ob sie irgendwie eine gestörte
persönlichkeit haben ob sie denken
gegenstände hätten ein eigenes leben
egal
kaufen sie einfach nur der rest zwischen
am frühen abend
linda erwartet ihren neuen freund sam
die friseurin hat keine ahnung wie der
33 jährige auf ihn reagieren wird okay
der tut mir leid
der tut mir wirklich leid ist aber mit
seiner frau zusammen kommen ohne irgend
auch nur den leisesten funken von einer
ahnung davon zu haben wie verballert die
im schädel ist ein muss damit
auseinandersetzen dass wissen sie
einfach eine plastikpuppe für ihren sohn
hält lässt die kinder bei ihr zu gast
oder moment ist das ist die art und
weise sind wir weit zu bringen ist die
schwaben erst direkt sowohl also wenn du
schwanger bist der beschluss dann bin
ich raus aus dem laden immerhin so
schlagen so vernünftig es sieht das ihm
schon mal sagt kollege setzt sich lieber
hin glaubt mir ich hab mein geist
kranken dachschaden was ich dir gleich
sagen würde würde ich komplett aus den
latschen stefan also selbst dich erstmal
es gibt da draußen
er musste ja erstellt aber diese
situation vor leute ihr seid mit eurer
freundin oder einem freund und er oder
sie meint ich gehe mal kurz in die küche
kommt zurück hatten scheiß baby
aufnahmen und das ding ist aus plastik
einfach 25 die ist schon bewusst dass
nur eine puppe ist oder ein beliebter
fahrstuhl ich jetzt gerade oder weiter
er hat gar keinen bock der ja er hat da
wirklich keinen bock drauf haben wir
über leute ich glaube nicht also ich
würde einfach nach einem langen
arbeitstag nach hause kommen will was
essen und dann schleppt seine freundin
einfach gegenstände an und erzählt dass
es ihre kinder sind hier das ist meine
tochter jacqueline wir gehören jetzt
zusammen
nein habe ich jetzt eine freundin die
gerade aus der klasse ja
in der nacht lava samy art nicht was
linda im schilde führt
all das wird nicht gut ausgehen das wird
nicht nur das gehen er geht nachts
runter da wird über in der nacht wach
und geht runter in deren wohnung das ist
richtiger horror movie schade
du kannst du nicht richtig
[Musik]
ja ok ciao ciao
er ist ein richtiger psycho ist das ist
keine hilfe folge
die 1 steht ist aber früh gestört ich
habe keinen bock mehr auf der beträge
ganz ehrlich leute ich darüber dass wir
auch genug gesehen alles was wir uns
weiter jetzt noch geben würden würde
unsere geistige gesundheit glaube ich
nicht positiv beeinflussen glaubt mir
leute lieber ein ende mit schrecken als
ein schrecken ohne ende
falls ihr den schreck aber nicht enden
lassen wollte habe ich euch hier drüben
eine playlist mit einem einen hilfe
nations hin gepackt vielen dank fürs
schon so weit heute und bis zum nächsten